[موسيقى]
. لا يزال الوضع العالمي صعبًا في
عدد المناطق في احتمال صراع واحد
ظهرت بؤر توتر جديدة
يسبب قلقا جديا
تتراكم مباشرة باللغة الروسية
حدود مجموعة رينات العسكرية الأمريكية
أيضا إجراء تمارين واسعة النطاق
بما في ذلك غير المخطط لنا للغاية
تقلق بشأن ما يقترب من روسيا
توسيع العناصر إلى الكرة الأرضية
أنت تسأل عن ira
[موسيقى]
إن روسيا تعني كل واحد على قدم المساواة
الأمن في جميع أنحاء منطقة أوراسيا
الفضاء
بالطبع ، كما لوحظ بالفعل في القضية
من الواضح أن الاستمرار عدواني ، أليس كذلك
الزملاء الغربيون ، سوف نتعهد
ردود عسكرية وعسكرية مناسبة على
تحركات غير ودية للرد بقسوة
وأريد أن أؤكد أن لدينا هذا بالكامل
الصحيح
لدينا كل الحق في التصرف
مصممة لتوفير الأمن و
السيادة الروسية
[موسيقى]